Disney has officially announced that it
will be delaying the release of its much
mocked cartoonishly lib liveaction
remake of Snow White or sand beige as I
call it given the emphasis on diversity
casting I'm not saying that Jeremy
boring is single-handedly responsible
for Disney's delay I don't know that he
did it single-handedly but I'm quite
confident that if say seven hands were
involved at least six of them were
Jeremy
for a comparison here is Disney's new
Snow White you said you were bringing a
Modern Edge to it on stage what do you
mean by that I just mean that it's no
longer
1937 and we absolutely wrote a snow
white that is she's not going to be
saved by the prince she's not going to
be safe with the prince and she's not
going to be dreaming about true love
she's dreaming about becoming the leader
she knows she can be sounds great here's
our Snow White by 2030 it's predicted
that 45% of women will be unmarried and
childless and why do you think that is
well it's because we've been told that
you know men are trash and that our
career is the only thing that matters
and that marriage and children will
inhibit that which is unnatural that is
biologically unnatural for women that
does sound great that's I mean what's
happening is really bad but the fact
that our Snow White realizes that that's
a problem and that girls actually do
want a prince and they do want like
normal stuff that's a good sign Disney
is obviously reacting to the Daily wire
announcement that we will be releasing
our version side by side with theirs and
Disney is also reacting to the terrible
reaction that their remake has been
getting among the public and then the
final nail in the coffin of this
remake's release came by way of South
Park just last week everyone I cared
about has been systematically replaced
and finally I want to scream and I'm
like why are they replacing every single
character with someone who is diverse
but then Kenny's like it's not our fault
it's cuz of Kathleen Kennedy but then
Kathleen Kennedy just like it make it my
name and everyone in town is like no
please cathine Kennedy stop ruining
everything but cathine Kennedy is all
like put another gay diverse woman in it
make it more lame and the Disney stock
just keeps going down and down and down
and then Bob is all like no it's going
my no make it more lame that is exactly
what they're doing and that is why we
hate the diversity equity and inclusion
casting and writing in movies we don't
hate it for the reason that the libs
think it's not that we conservatives or
forget conservatives that we normal
people are opposed to diversity exactly
what we oppose is
dishonesty the reason that we don't like
it when Hollywood replaces every white
guy with indigenous black lesbian
pygmies is that that is not how the
world really works in the real world not
every white man is an idiot or a villain
most white guys are actually pretty
decent fellas
in the real world not every woman or
person of color or other type of self-
styled grieved minority is perfect some
of them believe it or not actually have
complexity of character in the real
world not every single romantic couple
is interracial it happens I'm not
opposed to it when it does some of my
best friends are interracial couples but
it's rare I looked it up it's it's like
8% of marriages in movies and TV today
it's like
80% in the real world most people don't
consider themselves gay or in the real
world conservatives believe it or not
are not always ignorant stupid
malevolent Hicks sometimes those things
happen so it's fine to depict it
sometimes but the problem with the new
representation in Hollywood is that it
doesn't represent reality more often
than not it totally flips reality and
that is super dup
lame and so people tune the fantasists
out and they start to tune into
Alternatives I'm Michael nolles this is
the Michael nolles
[Music]
show welcome back to the show this
episode is brought to you by
good ranchers get great me at a secure
price and 30 bucks off your order with
my code nolles kwes go to
goodranchers.com use code nolles today
this is the first opportunity I've had
on the show to discuss the incredible
juicy good ranchers double cheeseburger
that sweet little Alisa made me the
other night it was just so mathw
watering and delicious we'll get into
good ranchers more a little bit later we
will also get into the New Yorker who is
going viral for bullying a pro hamon sky
and Everyone likes this clip especially
people on the right
but people on the right are having
trouble articulating why they like this
clip because it contradicts a lot of
things that we have been saying in
recent years that were kind of BS cancel
culture and all that we'll get into it
first though speaking of costumes and
diversity Halloween is upon us and a New
Jersey school district has cancelled
Halloween celebrations this New Jersey
school district has banned costumes from
the schools because of concerns over
diversity equity and inclusion the
decision was made by superintendent
Ronald Taylor of the South Orange and
Maplewood School District just west of
nework the the costumes will be banned
uh there will be be uh no Halloween
celebrations during school hours here's
why quote each year questions arise from
families students and staff about what s
so MSD schools will be doing regarding
Halloween is promoting School sponsored
Halloween activities creating indirect
and unintentional Financial hardships
for students and families okay first of
all you can throw a sheet on cut out a
couple of eyes put like a little spooky
mouth on it or something and you're a
ghost you could you could you could just
draw like you know a little scar on your
face and put a couple fake nails in your
neck and your Frankenstein it's not that
expensive to do some kind of costume uh
do school sponsored Halloween activities
violate the Dignity of some of our
students and families either culturally
or religiously okay there that's
actually what they're concerned
about if if a white kid wears a sombrero
is it going to be an international
incident and everyone's going to get
fired and canceled for it does the
promotion of school sponsored Halloween
activities create tensions with the
equity and access values of SD I don't
even know what that means that's just
that that's just like blah blah blah
gabble gabble GOG nonsense gibberish to
follow their actual concern this is
actually slight digression this is what
happens in Washington when uh staffers
are presenting policy options to a
principal to you know a congressman or a
president or something is they'll give
three options and the first one is not a
good option the second one is the only
workable option and the third option is
also not workable it doesn't make any
sense and so it's like a policy sandwich
where the person has to pick the one in
the middle that's like here they say
well maybe it's too expensive but no
that's not a good excuse and well it
violates multiculturalism and Dei and
political correctness that's what
they're actually concerned about and
then the third one it creates tensions
with equity and access values that's not
even is that's barely English that's
barely a
semantically meaningful sentence but
it's about it's about Dei and why is it
about Dei it it does go beyond just
wokeness it does go beyond just
political correctness here it actually
starts to hint at a problem with
diversity as the highest possible
value
because if you have nothing holding you
all together as a society then you're
not going to be able to have shared
festivals you're not going to be able to
have any shared ritual at all it'll be
misinterpreted you won't you won't have
the ability to interpret anything you're
saying because you're going to be
speaking different languages you're
going to have totally different sets of
beliefs you're going to Value totally
different things that is actually a
problem with diversity so in the United
States it used to be the case that when
we would take people in we would just
insist that they assimilate to our
culture and share our beliefs and just
get with the program and drop their
native languages and drop their native
traditions and just get on board with
what we're doing and if that's the case
then you don't need to worry about
potentially offending the indigenous
black lesbian Muslim pygmy that that
doesn't like your Frankenstein costume
for whatever reason because you say look
this is what we do you come to this
country you get on board you do what we
do you don't like it leave then don't
come you know we're not we're not
begging you to come here you're the one
who begged to come so you know get on
board with the
program but if your country exalts
diversity as an end unto itself if your
country believes that any kind of
Conformity especially a Conformity to
the native culture is a bad thing then
you're not going to be able to do that
and then it's just all going to be super
lame it's it's not even that you're
going to just come to a new agreement on
what costumes are acceptable you're
going to just completely obliterate the
old festival and what you will replace
it with is not new forms of Halloween
costumes you'll replace it with new
festivals so we no longer have
Halloween we no longer have
Thanksgiving that's that's an indigenous
people's day we no longer have Columbus
Day that's another indigenous people's
day we no longer have Christmas that's
not all now in the Public Square or at
least the Liberals really want to keep
it out of the Public Square and instead
what do we have we
have pride month we have Earth Day we
have all these other festivals that the
Liberals insist
upon which is super lame it's just as
lame as everything that Disney is doing
now speaking of ending
things there is a candidate who is
finally dropped out of the presidential
race who is it is it ASA Hutchinson is
it Doug burgo
is it Chris Christie no it's the former
Vice President of the United States Mike
Pence I just couldn't sit this one
out but the Bible tells
us that there's a time for every purpose
under
heaven and traveling across the country
over the past 6
months I came here to say it's become
clear to
me this is not my
time
so after much prayer and
deliberation I have decided to suspend
my campaign for president effective
today this is the mature thing to do
pence was giving a speech in front of
the Republican Jewish Coalition there
were a lot of other candidates who were
speaking before that group and so Pence
says okay this is as good a time as any
to say I'm dropping out of the
race the fact that Doug beram has made
it longer in this race than Mike Pence
has is a scandal but neither of them are
going to become president and so what
Mike Pence is doing here is what Scott
Walker did in 2016 which is to say okay
I gave it a good shot I was in early but
there's no path to Victory here and so I
could drag it out and get more publicity
time and take a few more shots at Trump
and maybe audition for a a cable news
gig or something but no I don't want to
do that if I'm not going to be president
I'm out and that's what Scott did in
2016 that's what Mike Pence is doing
here uh very mature thing to do what a
lot of anti-trump Republicans are hoping
for here is that this will be the
beginning
of the other also rans dropping out and
therefore consolidating support against
Donald Trump but there's a little
problem with that strategy which was
proven on the very same day that Pence
dropped out we'll get to that in one
second first though you know Mike
Pence's a very pro-life guy and I'm a
pro-life guy and a lot of you were
extremely pro-life I hope all of you
will become pro-life one of the great
organizations out there helping women
and advancing the cause of Life Is
pre-born Right Now go to pre-born docomo
did you know that Margaret Sanger the
founder of Planned Parenthood was a
eugenicist well if not I would recommend
you look into her background when you
see the disproportionate number of
abortion clinics located in black
neighborhoods it says it all thankfully
pre-born exists to bring mothers and
babies together by providing free
ultrasounds and many other amazing
resources to expecting mothers all
services are free and assistance is
provided for up to 2 years pre-born is
truly life-changing but don't just take
my word for it listen to this powerful
testimonial I was sobbing it was a a cry
for prayer for God I'm so sorry please
so I got on the internet and I looked up
how can you stop an abortion from only
taking the first pill and I just started
seeing like abortion pill reverse is
this real and I found a hotline number
so I'm like if please God let me call
this number be real I CAU it and
somebody actually answered the phone
Miss I really need help um I mistakenly
took a pill and I'm so scared I don't
know what to do please I just was like
panicking they get me started
immediately on progesterone and told me
everything like it's going to be okay
when I came here I it was the my heart
was so warm somebody would go as hard as
if it was their children to make sure
your child is going to be alive and stay
safe so I really want it I want a lot of
people to know it's it's it's POS
possible you can save your baby you can
reverse that abortion pre-born needs us
the pro-life Community to stand up for
the babies and mothers who need our help
one ultrasound is just $28 and $140 will
help Rescue five babies pre-born has a
100% charity rating so you can give with
confidence let's join together and help
mothers in crisis choose life just style
pound 250 say the keyword baby that's
pound
250 say baby or visit pre-born docomo
kwes that is pre-born
docomo
kwes so the theory is Pence drops out
pretty soon all the other also Rands are
going to drop out and that's going to
consolidate the race down to just one or
two or maybe three anti-trump candidates
and then with all that extra support
they're going to bring a real challenge
to Donald Trump they're going to kick
him out of his top spot for the
Republican nomination and then
everything will be hunky dory the reason
I'm skeptical of that strategy is Pence
wasn't the only person to drop out of
the race over the weekend our pal Larry
Elder also dropped out of the race Larry
failed to make it to the debates he
almost made it to the first debate
unfortunately his the poll that had him
above the threshold did not count
because it had done work with Donald
Trump so Larry was excluded kind of on a
technicality and the campaign wasn't
going to go anywhere so Larry drops out
but when Larry dropped out unlike Mike
Larry endorsed Donald Trump he says it
is time to unite behind real Donald
Trump to beat Joe Biden so okay Pence is
out obviously not endorsing Trump
Larry's out he's endorsing Trump the
question is who will the other
candidates endorse when they inevitably
drop
out Chris Christie is not going to
endorse
Trump what about Doug bergam I don't
know I don't know who bergham is going
to endorse what
about ASA Hutchinson probably he won't
endorse Trump so you could he could give
his support to the non-trump candidate
what about oh I don't know Tim Scott I
don't know who Tim Scott's going to
endorse look maybe Tim Scott gets a
nomination probably unlikely I don't I
don't know would he if he if he were to
drop out would Tim Scott endorse Ronda
santis would Tim Scott endorse Nikki
Haley or would Tim Scott endorse Trump
you don't really know what about Nikki
if Nikki were to drop out would she
endorse to santis or
Trump a lot of people are say oh she
would endorse to santis she's I'm not so
sure about she worked for Donald Trump
she said very nice things about Donald
Trump she said she wouldn't run for
president if Trump were running for
reelection if Trump is looking like the
stronger
candidate a lot of the also rans are
going to endorse
Trump as as of now Nikki is going to run
hard hard against Trump because she
wants to take the nomination from him
but if it ever came to the point where
she says she's not going to win I don't
know Des santis obviously cannot endorse
Trump because he has he has made himself
the chief anti-trump candidate in the
race but if the DeSantis campaign is
counting on the other candidates
dropping out and just one by one
endorsing him I'm not convinced that's
going to happen because what what would
happen is especially if Trump is still
looking dominant in the polls he'll just
offer them something he'll oh you could
be cabinet position you could
potentially be my running mate you could
do this that or the other thing and
politicians are very good at pursuing
their own
interest
and if they're getting a good offer from
Trump they're not going to endorse D
santis so now probably the disantis
campaign is going to be working behind
the scenes trying to get these
candidates to drop out to say if you
endorse me I'll make you Secretary of
State if you do this that or the other
thing but it's going to be much more
persuasive if his polling gets better so
it's a little bit of a of a Catch 22 for
for Ronda santis right here he needs the
other candidates to drop out and endorse
him for his poll numbers to go up to
beat Trump but the only way he's going
to convince them to endorse him is if
his poll numbers already start to move
up and they think that they've got a a
shorer bet in the santis than with Trump
is that strategy going to work I'm not
convinced but that is the that is the
last ditch strategy for the for any
anti-trump candidate is okay the
anti-trump candidates need to drop out
consolidate the field around one
anti-trump candidate I just don't know
that that is going to happen
now as for the other candidates St in
the race as for Nikki Haley Nikki just
came out big shot at the uh educational
establishment she said that these
schools that are the supporting groups
that are supporting Hamas and terrorism
we're going to defund them when I'm
president here's what she said you can't
fight anti-Semitism if you can't Define
it Joe Biden and the left refused to
call anti-zionism anti-Semitism so
belief
opposition to the belief that the nation
state of Israel has a right to exist
where it
exists uh if a school won't call that
anti-Semitism so just overt bigoted Jew
hatred then as president I will change
the official Federal definition of
anti-semitism to include denying
Israel's right to exist and I will pull
schools tax exemption status if they do
not combat anti-Semitism in all of its
forms in accordance with federal law
College campuses are allowed to have
Free Speech but they are not free to
spread hate that supports terrorism
Federal Law requires schools to combat
anti-Semitism we will give this law
teeth and we will enforce it the United
States of America will not use taxpayer
dollars to fund anti-Semitism period the
October 7th massacre in Israel and the
ensuing weeks have proven what many of
us have long known there is no
difference between anti- Zionism and
anti-Semitism in order to combat
anti-Semitism we have to Define it that
starts at the top so she's
saying opposition to
the nation state of Israel existential
opposition is tantamount to any other
kind of Jew hatred that we've seen
throughout all of history and as
president I'm going to use federal law
to stamp that out and a lot of people
are attacking Nikki here for uh opposing
Free Speech or violating the First
Amendment or whatever but then other
people are saying no look it's a it's a
school it's a university people have
Free Speech but they don't have the
right to Federal funding for their free
speech they don't have a right to
materially support terrorism as some
people are calling
this I love the idea in principle this
is exactly what I was talking about in
my book speechless controlling words
controlling Minds my only problem with
what Nikki is proposing here
is why stop here my only problem with
what Nikki is proposing here is it
doesn't go nearly far enough now when
you want your dog to go further in life
and Health you got to check out Ruff
greens right now go to Ruff greens.com
naturopathic doctor Dennis black the
founder of Ruff greens is focused on
improving the health of every dog in
America dog food may as well be dead
food since it contains very little
nutritional value let rough greens bring
your dog's food back to life rough
greens is a supplement that contains all
the necessary vitamins minerals
probiotics Omega oils digestive enzymes
and antioxidants that your dog needs
okay I've got a stepbrother who has this
dog and you know I'm you know lukewarm
on my step brother but the dog is a nice
enough dog and so I made sure to send
that dog some really good stuff from
rough greens just sprinkle rough Greens
on their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough greens
how many more words to start with r can
I find it improves bad breath it
supports healthy joints it boosts energy
levels right now Dr Dennis black is so
confident that this will improve your
dog's health he's offering our listeners
a free jump start trial bag get a free
jump start trial bag delivered straight
to your door in just a few business days
go to Ruff greens.com or call 844
rf123 that is rfffg greens.com or call
844 rfff ruff1 123 today you have been
asking us for an alternative in kids
media it's finally here the dailywire
has just launched bent key our brand new
kids entertainment platform we are sick
of Hollywood pushing leftist propaganda
on our kids and now there's finally an
answer for those looking for children's
shows that we can trust bent key is
dedicated to creating the next
generation of Timeless stories that
transport kids into a world of Adventure
imagination and joy this is exactly what
parents have been waiting for the
content is amazing it's high quality
it's fun my kids love it I could never
have imagined that the daily wire was
going to provide all of this for our
members without increasing the annual
price of membership in fact I suggested
that they do increase the annual price
of membership because it's very
expensive content but the DW xec said
nope we're doing it for free this is the
greatest greatest value ad that we have
ever given it's a $99 value that you get
totally free which goes to show that we
don't just talk about changing culture
we put it into action we really believe
in what we're doing if you are already a
daily wi plus member you already have
bent key just download the app to start
streaming now if you're not a member
there's never been more value to joining
than right now you get all of the daily
wi plusus content that you know and love
plus bent key at no additional cost go
to dailywire.com subscribe right now to
start streaming the next generation of
kids
entertainment so Nikki haly is saying
anti-zionism opposition to the
historical movement of Zionism and the
return of Jews from all around the world
to the Holy Land and the establishment
of the state of Israel that that is
tantamount to Jew hatred and it's going
to spill out into horrific events like
we saw on October 7th when Hamas comes
over and and exercises a pgr of Jews
just Slaughters people rapes pillages
kills and burns and the fact that this
is being celebrated on American
University camp campuses means we need
to defund these campuses we need to pull
the grants it it's not it's not a
curtailing of free speech rather it is a
refusal to pay for the support of
terrorism we're going to enforce the law
to do it okay Tim Scott said a similar
thing Tim Scott said the same thing
about pelg grants and
anti-Semitism my only issue with this
is why stop at
anti-Semitism this is the this is the
thesis of my book the book with
words why yes of course we have the
right to set standards yes of course we
the people through our elected
representatives have the right to set
norms and standards and we don't need to
tolerate Pro Hamas clubs at universities
duh but if we're going to wield this
power why would we not also wield it
against the anti-white indoctrination
that takes place on every University
campus in America that tells students
that white wh is evil that that being a
white person is a social pathology that
needs to be abolished that white people
are evil and some cases you have you've
had professors describe white people as
the ice people I'm thinking of Professor
Jeff Infamous at
cuni who's actually whose nephew is
hakee jeffre now who's the Democrat
leader in the US
Congress the white people are the evil
ice people and black people are the
people of the Sun and that's why we need
to abolish whiteness why not if we're
going to wield government power to
curtail people's opinions and discourage
them on campus why would we stop at
anti-Semitism certainly we should keep
going to the anti-white indoctrination
that is that is evil and base and
obviously racist and not fit for a
proper education what about the
anti-male
indoctrination all of these University
campuses teach people that masculinity
is toxic and men need to be feared and
frankly gelded if we're going to have a
good Society what about the anti
Christian indoctrination that takes
place on every University campus in
America how about we start pulling
funding because of that
too while while a lot of people on the
right are criticizing Nikki and Tim
Scott for curtailing free speech in the
effort to oppose anti-Semitism I think
we need to recognize that all societies
have standards all societies have norms
and here while we should obviously
oppose
anti-Semitism we should also oppose
anti- whiteness we should also oppose
anti-
masculinity anti- manliness we should
certainly oppose
anti-christianity let's start we're
going to wield that power let's wield it
baby let's not wield it just a little
tiny bit let's wield
it let let's do it with our whole chests
let's wield it in a way that is in line
with the American political tradition
and that is conducive to Virtue and
human flourishing now Governor DeSantis
has said a similar thing he's come out
and said we need to defund these Pro
Hamas groups Pro Palestine groups on on
college campuses they're providing
material support to terrorism and that
is why when we use the government to
shut them up it's not cancel culture
this is not cancel culture uh this group
they themselves said in the aftermath of
the Hamas attack that they don't just
stand stand in solidarity that they are
part uh of this Hamas movement and so
yeah you have a right to go out and
demonstrate but you can't provide
material support to terrorism they've
linked themselves to Hamas and so we
absolutely desertified them uh they
should not get one red scent of taxpayer
dollars uh and we also have strong laws
in Florida against fundraising for
groups like Kamas and we are enforcing
those vigorously that's not a First
Amendment issue that's a material
support to terrorism
issue Governor Dan santis is a very
smart man he's generally right on
virtually all of the issues and he's a
politician running for president and so
sometimes politicians
oversimplify sometimes for the sake of
expedience politicians say things that
are not exactly true but they broadly
get the point across in the end and I
think this is one of those instances I
think conservatives are going to twist
themselves into a hundred logical knots
over trying to explain how wielding
government power to censor Pro Palestine
Liberation groups is not cancel culture
of course it's cancel culture if this is
not cancel culture I do not know what
cancel culture is and that's fine it's
fine
guys I the reason they have to twist
themselves into kns is because they
spent five years talking about how
terrible cancel culture is but some of
us you know I hate to say I told you so
some of us did not spend five years
talking about how great how terrible
cancel culture is in fact some of us
spend a lot of time talking about how
cancel culture is perfectly fine it's
ordinary it's normal cancel culture is
just a part of human behavior and
political
society that it is not the act of
cancelling people that is good or bad
but it's what you cancel someone for if
you cancel somebody if you ruin their
reputation you ostracize them from
society you persecute them you drive
them out of of polite company because
they say that or because they say that
they love their country or because
they're Christian or be that that's
bad but if you ostracize someone and you
cancel them and you make them face
professional or academic consequences
for saying evil things and for doing
evil things and supporting I don't know
terrorists or something like that in
this case that's not a bad thing that's
called having standards that's called
being a society that discerns between
good and evil like all societies
must so they're all going to twist
themselves into knots no no this isn't
cancel culture because when the when the
pro Palestine Liberation groups speak
out their very speech is providing
material support to H okay whatever sure
whatever whatever helps you guys sleep
at night but it is cancel culture and
you're you're seeding the argument that
it's sometimes good to cancel people and
frankly it is you're right I'm glad I'm
glad that that it eventually after five
years conservatives have come to admit
this fact so now let's
let's discern between good and bad and
right and wrong and true and false and
let's wield that power in a just way the
left wields that power in a bad way
toward ends that are destructive we
should wield it in a good way toward
ends that are edifying great example of
this just came out of New York City here
is the classic New Yorker taking umbrage
at the fact that some guy was tearing
down posters of the missing hostages who
were taken by Hamas I'm telling
you jewi he's not Jewish I don't know if
he is matter This Is Us New York City
you don't have right to touch this a
free country you can wave your Palestine
flag and say death to the Jews or
America whenever you want but we can put
a signs okay then don't rip that down
you are doing something you're offending
us
mother yeah you are when you throw that
on the floor you're lit in the city in a
minute I'm going to lit
floor with you so move the on do you
have proof they're not kidna no so shut
the
up I know that's what you
want maybe it's because I'm a New Yorker
myself but this kind of reaction I love
it now you know what the
Nerds and the Eggheads and the
ideologues are going to say even on the
right they're going to say um uh
actually uh that man is threatening that
other man's free speech he's actually we
should be able to have a reasonable
debate in the free Marketplace of ideas
and you should yeah shut up nerd I like
that guy's argument more when he goes
yeah you're offending me and I don't
like that so you stop ripping those
signs down and on top of offending all
of us you're littering and in a minute
I'm going to litter your face on the
floor if you don't put it back and get
out of here I love it that's a beautiful
thing that's cancel culture that's the
good kind of cancel culture this goes so
much deeper than the war in the Middle
East put the war in the Middle East put
the horrific terror attack put the
terrible situation where hostages are
still being held by Hamas put all of
those particular circumstances aside for
a
second this is about the right of
communities to set and enforce their own
standards the best thing that guy said
there was he goes you're offending us
mother effer and so many conservatives
are going to say well you know um I I
don't have obligation to respect your
feelings and actually I could say
whatever I want without consequences
because we need to just have debates all
the time no that's not really how
political Society
works we have the right to sensibilities
we have the right to preferences not
just individual preferences and
sensibilities but communal preferences
and sensibilities we have the right to
standards and
behavior and that guy that New York
classic New Yorker just coming out said
keep it up watch one more time I'm going
to show you what I'm going to do that is
actually the right attitude it reminds
me of that base level of conservatism
that even we think of New York as being
very left-wing there is a base level of
conservatism to a lot of New
Yorkers you see it right
now in in New York immigration is
threatening the whole city because as
this flood of migrants comes across as
we're going to take in what 3 four
million illegal immigrants this year a
lot of them are going to New York and
even the liberal Democrats are saying
this is a big threat to the whole city
there's a poll that just came out a
large and growing majority of New
Yorkers say that the illegal immigrants
pose a quote serious
problem almost 60% agree with the mayor
liberal Democrat mayor Eric Adams who
says that the migrants could quote
destroy New York City this is according
to a Sienna College
poll and this shouldn't be all that
shocking one New Yorkers have a based
level of conservatism largely because of
foulmouthed
Italians but
two immigration was always a bipartisan
issue it it's only become
too and the Republicans saying well
actually the best the Republicans could
muster was hey stop that illegal
immigration but we can still take
millions and millions more legal
immigrants but you still have that
problem of assimilation so now things
are finally getting back to normal back
in the 1990s Bill Clinton was at least
he talked very tough on illegal
immigration so this is obviously
terrible Republicans and Democrats
agreed and then became a partisan
ideological issue for a while and as
long as the the consequence of mass
migration were only being felt in those
border towns only in those awful red
States the Democrats didn't care now
that the illegal immigrants are being
sent by people like Governor Abbott of
Texas or Governor Dan santis of Florida
being sent to Martha's Vineyard being
sent to New York City being sent to
Chicago being sent to rth Beach Delaware
now all of a sudden the majority of
everyone is agreeing oh wow this poses a
serious problem of
course of course this actually I know we
consider immigration now to be a really
hot button issue that no one wants to
touch there has all for most of American
History been broad bipartisan consensus
on how too much migration is a very bad
thing and it seems that that consensus
is coming back
again now when you want to
stop not not bad political issues but
just bad pathogen issues from infecting
your environment you got to check out in
vro Lans right now go to EK .c use code
NES did you know that the flu season
costs Americans over 11 billion billion
with a B dollars every year kids get
sick they miss school parents stay home
from work to take care of their kids
then they get sick themselves that's why
we have enviral cleanse in our office we
have right now a wonderful offer for our
listeners 30% off make sure to act fast
since the sale is ending soon and viroc
cleanse is an inhome air purifying unit
proven to capture and Destroy flu
viruses bacteria toxins molden allergens
from your home enviral cleanse
technology is so powerful it was chosen
to purify the air systems on board Navy
ships and Subs Enviro cleanse helps keep
our service men and women healthier and
it can help you and your family stay
healthier too enviral cleanse is the
only home air purifier that promises
Better Health by keeping your home free
of Cold and Flu viruses go to EK
pure.com use code NES KES for 330% off
your enviral cleanse home air
purification unit EK pure.com promo code
NES kwes for
330% off my favorite comment on Friday
is from Ulisses Sterling 8659 who says
the silly thing about the greata AI is
that it's so silly that her followers
would agree that's so true the greata AI
was where she you know was developed uh
just by some random computer but it
looked real and convincing and she said
we need when we Supply the people in war
we need vegan grenades we need low
emission tanks we need and you're so
right that it took me about halfway
through to realize it was fake but
what's even spookier is that some of her
followers might not have known because
they would probably say those things
earnestly speaking of guns and
weapons the view the ladies of the view
have an important lesson to teach you
about the power of the
AR-15 and its uses in hunting I would
love to see an assault weapons ban like
President Reagan I don't believe they're
a sport or hunting um uh instrument it's
like shooting fish in a bucket but
that's my but also if you shoot with an
AR15 let's say you shoot a deer you
can't eat it because you basically
demolish in addition to that but the
Hunt is about an actual difficult
process not massacring bodies of any
kind but my point is I'd love to see
that Joy bayar seems to be confusing an
AR15 with a rocket launcher she she
seems to be confusing
an AR-15 with a landmine that would just
explode the
deer ironically she's somewhat correct
in what she said she said if you shoot a
deer with an AR-15 you won't be able to
eat it and that might be true because
the deer might get away because the
AR-15 round the 223 is probably too weak
to at least to humanely hunt deer and
actually certain places have
restrictions on the AR-15 for hunting
year for precisely that reason not
because it's going to explode the deer
not because it's I don't know it's like
a heat seeking missile that just
explodes and splatters venison all over
the place but because it's it's a little
weak it's a lot weaker than these people
think they have no idea which gets to
what I think is beneath a lot of the
political dysfunction that we have right
now which is not just evil ideology or
uh the tolerance and encouragement of
vice and sin all of which contribute to
our political
problems but the problem of blle
ignorance the fact that people are just
so
casually happily
indifferent to knowledge and the truth
and
skill it's astounding you
can't you can't run a society on bad
ideology it's not going to work out in
the end
you also can't just run a society on
ideology you need to possess some degree
of technical knowledge and competence to
run a society it's not enough just to
read Carl Marx or just to read Edmund
Burke or Aristotle for that matter you
also need to know how to how to do
plumbing you also need to know how to
grow food you also need to know how to
perform the basic functions of a society
and a society that doesn't know how guns
work a society that doesn't know how
human beings relate to animals certainly
as it regards food production that
Society is not going to do
well and you add on top of that bizarre
ideologies well I guess actually the the
the ble ignorance is a consequence of of
the ideological age which tells people
that when they go to school they don't
need to learn
anything real or
substantive they can just
read a bunch of theories disconnected
from reality they can just major in
gender studies to use an off- cited
example and that will prepare them for
life it will not do
so that's what we get on The View now
speaking of what people watch on TV
there is a poll that is surprising some
people but not me that shows that gen Z
the Zoomer
want fewer sex scenes in movies and TV
what what's wrong with these kids they
don't want to see a bunch of sex and
stuff no they don't you fdy Dy kids you
can just hear the voice of Gen X and the
Boomers and maybe even the Millennials
now you can hear that voice of the
perpetually cool you know everyone from
the Woodstock generation down to my own
generation they say man you don't want
to see sex man sex is cool you guys are
square why what do you mean why don't
you want to see that I'll tell you
exactly why so this poll
finds that in a survey of 1500 students
almost half of Zoomers age 13 to 24 said
sex is not needed for most TV shows and
movies a significant amount of people
44% said that romance is overused as a
plot
device why is that well I'll give you a
related note from that same study and
that might explain what's going on here
in 2023 more participants in the study
wanted to see a white man as the hero
now it's different from last year more
participants in the study said they
wanted to see a black man as the hero in
movies and TV shows now they're saying
they want to see a white man as the hero
why what's going on do these kids hate
sex they hate romance they hate black
people or something no it gets to
exactly what we were talking about at
the top of the
show people are being depr rived of an
important aspect of Reality by movies
and TV which are supposed to tell us
something about our
culture and because because they're
being deprived of that aspect of reality
they want more of it it's not that they
don't want relationships well Rel even
that term is so silly it's so clinical
it's not that they don't want love it's
not that they don't want romance it's
not even that they don't want sex but
they're inundated with it it's
everywhere everything is
sexualized there's ubiquitous porn
people dress like they're auditioning
for a strip club everywhere in public
and the even in the elementary schools
now you've got sexual indoctrination you
have actual pornography in elementary
school libraries now and being assigned
by
teachers so we got that that's taken
care of you know what we don't have in
this culture any emphasis on friendship
any emphasis on any kind of nonsexual
non-erotic relationship and so the
Zoomers who grew up in the stud culture
come out and they say yeah we'd like to
see that how about just like friendship
what is what is a friend people are so
lonely they're not lonely because
there's any lack of a hookup culture you
it's easier to hook up today than it
ever has been but it's very hard to make
a friend that's why they want to see
that why do more study participants want
to see a white man as the hero because
now coming out of Hollywood you never
see a white guy as a hero the white
guy's always the bumbling idiot or the
villain they they've got they're only
vicious and persons of color are perfect
and they have no character flaws they
have no complexity of character
whatsoever coming out of Hollywood so
when people see that they say wait
that's not really how reality Works
reality is I think a little more complex
than that and they they desire something
else this is the great conservative
constellation as I pointed out before
which is that reality doesn't go away
even when you live in a highly
ideological age reality is still there
and people at least occasionally brush
up with reality and they begin to desire
some connection between
their political order the entertainment
the laws the
everything and reality that's happening
again it's music Monday Baby the rest of
the show continues now you do not want
to miss it become a member use code no
SCS it check out for two months for on
all annual
[Music]
plans